during which we have a gathered of town
link where you're you know
welcome to join uh for socializing
uh and then we'll resume uh later on at
uh i think noon california time for the
third talk yes uh that would be stefan
yeah so that's the plan uh otherwise
uh let's go ahead with the lane stuff
thank you very much for being here
yeah thanks so much for inviting me um
i'm obviously very happy to virtually be
here
i guess this morning when i was teaching
my class
one of my students made fun of me with
this comic
so i'll let you look at it and figure
out
what you need to do
okay so i'd like to talk about a fun
topic
essentially blockchain inspired
protocols where game theory meets crypto
and and again you know like zoom talks
are not like in person so if you have
questions like don't wait till the very
end just like interrupt me
and ask the more interactive the better
okay so i'm going to begin with the
motivating example that comes from like
a true personal
experience uh i guess this is not
uncommon
in the crypto community like you write a
paper and you discover that there's a
concurrent paper
that has exactly the same result and
this happened to me a couple of times
in fact it happened to me to to my first
ever crypto paper when i was still
a grad student and then it happened
again in 2013
and this time that the two papers even
have had exactly the same title
so turns out both papers were submitted
to eurocrypt
14 and then the program committee
decided uh to
um recommend hard merch so now the most
challenging question is
you know we have to decide who to
present the paper
and how do we do that
okay i mean of course a strong man's
solution is for me and shafi i mean
who's collector of the other paper to
wrestle it out but you know we are
cryptographers so we can find a more
civil
uh solution and so why not just run a
coin toss protocol right
in fact this is what we actually did
so kind task was first proposed in
blum's elegant paper back in 1983
and the way it works is the following so
both chavi and i
send a commitment to let's say some
blockchain
you can think of it as a public bulletin
board or like a broadcast channel
and then we basically both open our bits
and we take
the xr of the two bits in this case the
xor is one
so my preference is one shaft prefers
zero so i win in this case right this is
also what happened
our group presented the paper
okay so i mean i may be concerned that
shafi
is malicious like let's say she sees
that i have opened the commitment
and now she already knows she's going to
lose right so maybe she'll just apart
from the protocol
and and then in this case what do we do
uh
so we can just say you know if you apart
you forfeit you automatically lose and
then i win
anyway so this this was just basically
blum's idea
and um as i said this is called the coin
toss protocol
it has two requirements um first
correctness is very natural right so if
both parties run the protocol honestly
then the outcome has to be a random coin
and then we also want
fairness and the standard line of work
on multi-party competition
has a very strange notion of fairness i
will call it
strong fairness and this strange notion
requires that
even if shafi aborts i must nonetheless
output a completely unbiased coin
and unfortunately this is known to be
impossible
in the two-party setting or in the
multi-party setting
with dishonest majority and this was
like a famous law bound by cleve
back in 1986 uh i won't go into the
details here
but so it may seems like i'm
contradicting myself because you know
if there's a lower bound how can blanc's
coin toss
work and the key observation here is
that blank's protocol
actually achieves a strictly weaker
notion of fairness
and in this talk i will call it game
theoretic fairness
so in the protocol we've seen it's not
like
shafi cannot bias the coin right she
can't bias the coin
but only in the direction that hurts
herself and benefits me
and so essentially you know we can
imagine the players are rational and
they care about
maximizing some utility functioning and
fairness or gain theoretic security
requires that shafi
you know whatever she does she cannot
benefit herself
or hurt me um by deviating from the
honest protocol
so in other words another way to look at
this is that shaky's best response
is just to play honestly it doesn't help
her anyhow you know even if she deviated
and that's honest behavior is the
equilibrium state
okay so blunt's protocol achieves game
theoretic fairness in a two-party
setting
and of course a very natural question is
can we achieve game theoretic
coin toss in the multi-party setting so
imagine we now have m
parties and so i mean of course at this
moment
it's not clear what the formulation is
i'm going to ask you to hold that
thought
and i'll explain in a little bit and
before that i just want to mention there
are
like a couple trivial solutions that we
want to rule out right under very strong
assumptions let's say
if we are willing to assume honest
majority then a solution to this problem
is known essentially we know how to
achieve
um constant round honest majority uh mpc
in general
uh inconstant number of rounds right and
so
strong fairness i mean in some sense is
the best one can hope for
because it gives perfect unbiasedness
and but in a blockchain setting like
oftentimes let's say we are
playing lottery with the smart contracts
it's not
too reasonable to assume on this
majority because these players like
they're just pseudonyms and anyone can
make up arbitrarily many pseudonyms or
public keys and participate as many
players so like
it may well be that you know 99
of the players are controlled by one
entity
okay i mean of course um another trivial
solution is essentially just to assume
the problem away
like if we can have a trusted set up
that can choose like a random seed for
us
then the problem kind of just goes away
and and
i mean of course in the blockchain type
setting oftentimes we want to fully
decentralize we don't want to trust any
single party
and oftentimes also um
we want this coin to be unpredictable to
like we don't just want to
pass the coin a priory and then then it
wouldn't be unpredictable
so with this in mind let me refine the
problem statement right so i'm asking
assume corrupt majority and no trust is
set up in the plain model can we have
game theoretic fair coin toss in the
multi-party setting
so when we first started working on this
we discovered that this question
actually surprisingly hasn't been
considered in the literature at all like
you know um even though if you think
about the multi-party computation the
mtc lineup work
it started with blum's coin toss which
achieves game theoretic security
but then subsequently like all the work
on npc they consider the strong notion
of fairness
okay um so as i will explain
later actually even how to formulate the
problem is pretty challenging and
different
formulations can lead to different
feasibility results
okay so now suppose we can indeed
achieve and party coin toss within
theoretic fairness
the next question we may care about is
the complexity of such protocols
so for instance we can ask about the
wrong complexity of such protocols
okay so without further ado um
to understand an end party things
theoretic coin toss we first have to
define the problem
and there are two different formulations
that are very natural
and in this talk i'm going to actually
focus on the second one but i just want
to mention the first one very quickly
because then you can see like how
different formulation can lead to like
wildly different results
so in the first formulation you can
think of it as a binary roulette
let's say n players they each place a
bet
on either zero or one and then you toss
the coin and if the
unkind agrees with your bet you win
right and then suppose like everyone
puts in some one ether as the bet
and then we can just divide the pot
among the winners
and then the second formulation is
more like lottery or leader election so
we have m players and we are tossing an
n-way coin we want to elect
um a single winner and the winner takes
the whole pack
so what we discover is like essentially
for the first notion we can prove
and brought in possibility results for
several natural game theoretic notions
and what's interesting here is that we
find and that's like even how to define
game theoretic
fairness is not so clear like we
actually
came up with several definitions they're
different in the end party setting
but when we degenerate to the two-party
setting they they are kind of the same
as
that they are the same as uh blanc's
notion essentially
okay so as i said in this talk i just
want to focus on the second notion
um and
so what i want to mention is without
loss of generality we can assume like a
simple utility function so let's just
assume
the winner has utility one and everyone
has utility zero right we know
i mean in lottery maybe winner takes the
whole part but we can always just
rescale it
to one so this
leader election problem actually has a
lot of applications in decentralized
blockchain smart contract contexts
so for example imagine there's a smart
contract and it's looking for service
providers to provide some service like
let's say verifiable competition service
and the service provider is like elected
at random from some pool
and in exchange for providing the
service you'll get some reward
so everyone's like eager to be elected
and you know make a profit
okay so i will first explain a very
simple folklore protocol so we actually
have something concrete in mind
and then i'll elaborate on the game
theoretic notions again
and so here we have um four
cryptographers and they're trying to
elect the next
crypto pc chair i mean pc chair of
course is a lot of work
um but let's imagine somehow all of them
are eager to
you know have the opportunity to serve
the community so they all want to get
elected
and here's how the protocol works right
so essentially we pair them up
every pair will deal with each other
they play blum's protocol
elect the winner the winner survives to
the next round and then the two winners
will
duel again and elect the final winner
so if there are n players you can do it
in a tree-like fashion and it will take
log n rounds
so actually later in the talk we are
going to focus on improve
improving the round complexity
okay so at this moment
we can kind of try to understand what
fairness
uh property this very natural protocol
the tournament tree protocol can achieve
um so first if you think about it
this tournament 3 protocol actually
achieve achieves a very strong notion of
game theoretic fairness
in the sense that no coalition like no
matter how large the coalition is
cannot benefit itself because like the
only thing you can do is just abort
because this is a commit
open protocol there's basically nothing
else you can do you can abort
but in that case you just forfeit
and so there's no way to deviate to
benefit yourself
and also we also need this uh
we also have a second property which is
um any coalition
cannot harm the honest player cannot
harm actually any honest individual
because it's for the same reason right
i can the only thing i can do is support
but that just hurts me and harms
uh that just hurts me and benefits the
opponent
so the second property is also important
for example if i'm providing let's say
verifiable computation service to a
smart contract in exchange for rewards
it's in my interest to monopolize the
ecosystem
so maybe you know in the short term i
want to drive away all the competition
and like make other smaller players
leave and
you know maybe in the short term it
might might cost me something to do that
but i'm still interested in like
um harming let's say a single individual
okay so if a coalition can harm
individual players it also creates
this incentive like for the smaller
players to enter the system
okay so now um
the nice thing here is that again honest
behavior is an equilibrium
like if i join the system and i see
everyone else is behaving
honestly then my best response is just
to play honest
such a system incentivizes everyone to
behave honestly
so we say it's incentive compatible
and essentially no matter what your goal
is like you can be selfish and profit
seeking
you can be malicious and just trying to
harm other people like maybe trying to
monopolize the system
you can be paranoid and trying to defend
defend yourself
against the worst possible scenario like
no matter what your goal is you just
you always want to play honestly
so this is actually something very nice
for like these decentralized
blockchain type of applications
okay
so now we know that game theoretically
fair
leader election is possible in login
rounds with the tournament tree protocol
the interesting question is can we
achieve the same
in little or login rounds can we
asymptotically improve the run
complexity
and again remember we are dealing with
corrupt majority
and also going forward because like game
theoretically there is a mouthful right
going forward whenever
i say fair by default i mean game
theoretically fair
okay so to answer this question i mean
of course we start we've got to start
with some naive ideas
the first thing we want to try is just
take the tournament tree protocol
and compress it two rounds right so in
the tournament tree protocol
you do multiple rounds of commit and
open so why don't we just commit
everything up front and
open everything in the second round
well the point is like this doesn't work
for example imagine in this case shafi
and alessandro are
corrupted like they're in the coalition
and here's the definitive winning
strategy so let's say shafi commits to
zero zero
and alessandra commits to 1-1
and then they can look at the honest
players opening
and decide that one of one of them will
abort and they'll pick the right one to
apart such that the other one will
definitively win
okay so this very naive idea doesn't
work
and let me now talk about our results
so i'll first talk about the results at
a high level
and then i'll try to help you interpret
the results and then i'll go into
the construction
so first we prove that um if we impose
too strong a restriction on the style of
the protocol then there's a log and load
button like in some sense
tournamentary protocol like is the best
you can do
if you restrict yourself to protocols
that are in some sense very similar to
tournament tree
and what do i mean by tournament very
similar to tournament 3
like remember in the tournament 3
protocol like you do multiple rounds of
commits and then immediately open in the
next round
so if you are working with this
restriction then there's nothing much
um you can do like log n is the best
so i want you to think of the slower
bond as like sanity check for when we
design these protocols
so this is not a deal breaker right so
like who says we have to restrict
ourselves to
this very restrictive model and yes
can i ask why can't we just like commit
like do one round but commit
a number modulo the number of
participants
and i the same thing will um
the same thing can uh break the fairness
like let's say i can
the point is i can look at the honest
players coins
and decide what i want to commit so it's
not like simultaneous or atomic it's
like you know
you post something to the blockchain and
i already see your message and then i
can decide
what message i want to post so in in the
cryptography literature this is called
the russian model
and it also kind of very well captures
like
the the model you would actually have
like in the blockchain setting
like all the miners like the network
relays they already see the message
you want to post before like deciding
their own message like let's say um
um oh so
i guess i mean the point is like after
you open i can decide whether
to open mine like you control a bunch of
players right
so everyone first commit and then the
honest players open
and i can decide which of my own players
to abort
and maybe the rest open so in this way i
can bias the outcome
yeah like i think that's in the binary
case
there's only one bias which is the other
person wins
in the multi-person case you can change
among
the others who win and that's a
violation yes
yes okay right thank you so right so
that's a very good and
strongman example too okay
so now our upper bound
so we showed that if you are willing to
relax the fairness
to approximate notion of fairness i'll
explain this
in a little bit and moreover if you are
willing to
assume standard cryptographic
assumptions then we can actually achieve
log log n rounds right so in comparison
with the tournament tree protocol this
is an exponential improvement
so so i'll elaborate on two things
one is what is approximate fairness and
the other is like
what cryptographic assumption we need
okay so this is what i want to focus on
in this talk
so first what do i mean by approximate
fairness here
so i have a notion of epsilon fairness
and you may remember from the last slide
we can achieve
um little one uh it's actually also on
this slide we
achieve little one fairness so epsilon
equal to little one
so a protocol is said to be epsilon fair
if
the following two things hold so first
we want to make sure that no
polynomially bounded coefficient
can increase its expected utility by
more than epsilon
and second we want to make sure that no
polynomial time coalition
that contains almost all the other
players like it can
control up to one minus epsilon fraction
of the players
even such large coalitions cannot
reduce any honest individual's expected
utility
by more than epsilon okay
so there are a couple subtleties i want
to explain one is um
in the first notion our result actually
extends to coalitions
of arbitrary sizes right even like all
but one coalition
and we don't have this one minus epsilon
restriction and this is because actually
for the first notion
um um
it's actually kind of trivial to satisfy
when you have a really large correlation
so let's say you control n minus one
players
and like even normally if you play
honestly your utility is very close to
one
already and no matter how you deviate
you can only increase your utility to at
most one right so so like the
the relative increase is very little
just
by problem definition and this is not
true for the second
notion and that's why like in our
results we have
an a restriction on the coalition size
which is one minus epsilon
for the second uh second notion
we don't know how to actually achieve
our output one for the second notion so
it's an open question
so that's the first subtlety yes so the
protocol
does not depend on epsilon then
the protocol needs to know epsilon
epsilon is the parameter
of the protocol okay so okay fine so i
actually i'll give a more parameterized
version of the statement later and
you'll see how to parameterize it
depending on how much friends you want
okay
so in this talk i just want you to
assume epsilon is one percent even
though we prove something stronger i
mean this is just to
for simplicity in the talk
so i think i already alluded that this
so our notion
approximate notion is multiplicative so
in some sense like let's say the second
notion is saying the expected honest
utility
has to be at least one minus epsilon
over m
because if you play honestly and your
utility is one over n right because the
winner lets it get
that's one utility one so it cannot be
worse
than one minus epsilon over n
and this multiplication multiplicative
notion is more
um meaningful than additive in a lot of
these practical applications
like for example let's say in the
blockchain setting oftentimes we play
these games
repeatedly and like the absolute value
of the utility like
is not very meaningful and that's why we
go for this multiplicative
version okay so again
our philosophy here is to have incentive
compatibility we want the honest
behavior to be an equilibrium
in the sense that if everyone else is
behaving honestly then it makes very
little sense for me
to to deviate like maybe i can do just a
little bit better by deviating
but the relative gain is like so small
and
like maybe it's not worth the risk i'm
taking like i can be caught i can't be
exposed right so
in this sense it's incentive compatible
okay so this is something i won't have
time i'll defer this to the very end of
the talk most of the talk
i'll stick with these simple notions but
actually we proved something stronger in
our paper
um called sequential fairness i'll just
expand
one slide at the end talking about the
sequential notion
and this is related to what alessandro
was asking
and we actually proved a parametrized
version of the theorem
and essentially we show if your protocol
is our rounds
then we can achieve roughly speaking 2
to the minus r fairness
uh and this holds for any r greater than
some constant times log log n
like i mean if your r is log n rounds
you might just might as well just use
like
the tournament tree protocol so it's
only kind of meaningful
for like log log and to log in
okay so for the cryptographers in the
audience who might care like
it's actually quite interesting when we
compare with an approximate
strong fairness because like for strong
fairness we know
if you have an round protocol like in
the correct majority setting
you cannot hope for more than one
overall fairness so we actually have a
much sharper
approximation factor here
okay so our techniques are also quite
interesting
at very very high level we use um
extractors and honest majority npc
multi-party computation
to get these results and you should be
surprised here because i just said this
is a corrupt majority setting
so how can we actually make use of
honest majority mpc right
like why would honest majority npc give
any meaningful guarantee
but but you'll see in a little bit so
elaine i quite
a question uh your lower bound that you
mentioned earlier
it was specifically specifically in the
ideal
commitment reveal model does that mean
that in principle
there could be still some protocol that
for for computationally bounded parties
achieves uh um just
perfect fairness so first it's actually
in the ideal commit
immediately reveal model it's like
you're committing this round you reveal
in the next round and you repeat like
the tournament tree protocol
and then i basically even if so if you
are computationally bounded
uh setting if you are using commitment
only like not not in any like other
non-black box way then
i think that the lower bound would carry
over like unless you are doing something
like you know imaginative with your
commitments if you're just using it
as an ideal commitment you like if your
protocol
that is to say if the commitment can't
be replaced with the ideal commitment
then you are subject to the same lower
bound okay but
it is plot i mean i don't know if it's
possible or not but it may be possible
in principle to have a protocol where
there is no trade-off between the
the number of rounds and the the
the quality of the fairness oh yeah our
low back only holds
for like perfect perfect fairness in the
ideal model
so we don't know about proximate so like
we make actually
our protocol if you look at it in
comparison with the lower bound we are
assuming a couple more things one is
approximate
and the other is we are making more
assumptions than just commitment we are
using honest majority
constant round on this majority actually
we only need log log n round log log
around honest majority npc
and then we are using commitment but not
in the immediately open model we commit
and then it's opened
a few rounds later
so we actually don't know which of these
are needed but you know at least a
subset of these are needed to get this
result
so there is like an open question to
close things between the two
yeah yeah so to understand like which
like how do you reduce the assumptions
needed to get the upper bound
is interesting i mean again i think the
lower bound is more of a sanity check
and the only reason we had it is because
in the beginning we were trying in that
model
and we soon realized like it's not
possible i mean
the proof of the lower bound is like
pretty technical but
it kind of it was like how we arrived at
this uh
conclusion essentially great expertise
okay
yeah thanks for the question
okay so now let's actually dive into
technical
i'll start with the strongman scheme the
strongman scheme relies on the random
article
so don't be alarmed because you know i'm
going to just get rid of the random
article in the end
and furthermore the strongman scheme
doesn't satisfy our fairness requirement
but we'll fix them too okay
so here's the idea the very high level
idea is we we start with m players
we first down sample to some polylog
size committee and then from the polylog
size committee we elect the winner
so the second part we know how to solve
we just run the tournament tree protocol
and because
the committee is probably lock size the
tournament tree protocol now takes log
log n rounds
so the first part we don't know how to
solve yet and let's think about how to
um
how to get um the first part
so this approach is actually inspired by
um
proof-of-stake protocols so again here
we are trying to down select to a poly
log size committee right
and the idea here is for everyone to
post a bit to the blockchain
i toss a random coin i post it to the
blockchain we take the concatenation of
everyone's bids and we feed it into a
random article
and then the random article gives a
polylog size committee
so if you haven't heard of the term
random article before
you can just think of it as a completely
random function if you make a fresh
query
it just gives you a completely random
string if you make the same query as
before it gives you the same answer as
before
and so if anyone aparts will assume that
bit is zero
okay so let's think about
what this protocol gives us imagine the
rap players um
they form a coalition and of course
again the coalition can look at the
honest players coins
and then decide decide their own kinds
and of course it's in
their advantage because they want to try
different combinations of their coins
and pick the one that works the best for
them and
to um to maximize your utility
essentially what you should do is to
increase your representation in the
committee right
include as many as many of your players
as possible
in the committee because the committee
will run the tournament tree protocol
and the tournament tree protocol you can
think of it as like kind of ideal
okay so that's the coalition's objective
fortunately we can prove that let's say
the
entire universe has a 99
red and no matter what the adversary
does as long as the adversary is um
the coalition is computationally bonded
the committee has to be like roughly
speaking 99
corrupt as well like it's a very good
representation of the overall population
and the proof is actually
not too difficult like first we are
going to okay look at a fixed random
article query
and by taking a churn off bound we can
show that for a fixed random oracle
query
it's going to select a committee that's
good
and good means let's say roughly 99
correct and bad means more than 99.1
correct okay so the probability that the
committee is bad is negligibly small
and then remember we are going to assume
the adversary is computationally bounded
so it can make at most poly polynomially
many random article queries
so you can just take a union bound over
the polynomial factor
and you get this guarantee
okay
so just to quickly recap as i said uh
you know we have good news and bad news
like the good news is that we can prove
that large coalitions like even 99
coalitions
cannot benefit itself noticeably right
so like
remember this turnout bound this train
up on proof
holds for any constant fraction uh
coalition it can be one percent it can
be 99
it holds as long as constant fraction
um but there are a couple flaws with
this
naive solution and we will look at them
one by one the first flaw
is that a large coalition can harm a
single individual
and and at a very high level like this
churn of type bound gives you a
statistical guarantee about the
population
it doesn't give any meaningful guarantee
about any single individual
right so like if you're a large
coalition you want to harm some
individual
like what would you do you can look at
the honest coins and then try different
combinations of your own kinds
and make sure this user is excluded from
the committee and you can achieve this
with very high probability
okay so the second drawback is a small
correlation can actually benefit itself
significantly so at first sight this is
counterintuitive again because i just
said
large coalition cannot benefit itself
noticeably but now i'm seeing
like it's harder to defend against small
coalition right so why is this the case
and this again has to do with the notion
being multiplicative because like
for the large coalition like its utility
even if it plays honestly like it's
already very close to one
but whereas for like a small coalition
let's say a single individual
like my normal utility would be one over
n so even if i can just increase a tiny
bit let's say by one over n
i'm already doing twice that's better
right
so how can small uh coalition benefit
itself
i mean it's like the same kind of attack
it can look at honest coins and decide
the best
uh coin for herself and because it can
try both values zero and one
like you can do a backup envelope
calculation i can do like basically
twice
better than if i played honestly right
so here
and anything that's more than one plus
epsilon is considered
significant okay
so we're just going to try to overcome
these problems one by one
let's first think about how to solve the
first problem that is
a large coalition can harm a single
individual
so the reason why the large coalition
can harm an individual is because it can
choose its coins
to exclude that that person right and to
do that
you know it needs to know the player's
id so what if we just like hide all the
players ids
and then you wouldn't know who to target
so the idea is the following
everyone's going to pick a random
virtual id
and they're going to keep the random
virtual id secret and the virtual id is
like really what's being elected
by the random article
okay so you commit to your random id
puts it put in an envelope and now
you do this random article based
protocol but the random article is
as i said it's selecting virtual ids
rather than real player ids
so once you've selected the virtual ids
you open this commitment and now you
know the reverse mapping you can map
back
to the actual player ids and then from
this committee you select the winner
so there is actually a subtlety here
that would break things like because
if you think about it the correct player
the coalition player knows its own
virtual id right
so when the text it can perform is that
the coalition can
have everyone assign everyone the same
virtual id so we all choose the same
virtual id
and then we choose our coins such that
this specific virtual id
is included in the committee and in this
way we all get selected
and that's pretty bad and that's why we
need the following modification to the
protocol which is to say
the the player is only committing member
if
first its virtual id is selected by the
random article
and second and you're the only one who
selects that virtual id there's no
collision with other players so it turns
out something like this
would work i mean it's not exactly with
the parameters i show like we actually
need
the virtual id space to be a little bit
larger it needs to be n times
poly log n to have small collision
probability
uh i i won't go into the proof
so so this fixes the first problem but
it doesn't fix the second problem right
the small coalition can still benefit
itself because the small player
the individual player knows its own
virtual id it can still carefully choose
its kind
to help itself so how can we um
solve the second problem
okay so let's try to solve the second
problem now
and in fact i've already given away the
solution at the beginning of the talk i
said
there's going to be an honest majority
npc and here's
where it's going to get used so the idea
is we want to make sure the small
coalition or the individual player
doesn't know its virtual id
either and how can you achieve that so
we
let's say the virtual id contains two
parts like the first part is this
unmasked
virtual id which is what you select and
then
imagine everyone jointly selects a mask
permutation
so you're going to apply the mass
permutation to the unmasked virtual id
to get your final virtual id this is
kind of like xr in the two right
just in a different format
okay and how to select this
mask permutation i mean this is just
where we used on this majority npc
um we commit to this mass permutation up
front and we open it at the end
okay so in this way if you are a small
coalition right in this case
the coalition has two red layers
they cannot predict their virtual id
because they don't know the mass
permutation
so they don't know which virtual id to
help
and but if you control a very large
coalition let's say 99
then you control the npc because the npc
only secures against
uh like minority players so
in this case you can completely corrupt
the mpc you can control the outcome
but it doesn't matter because for large
coalition the first part of the
construction gives
security so that's the idea
okay so essentially
i've described like how to overcome
these two problems and but there's only
one
question left i promise we are going to
get rid of the random article
and we will do that so before that are
there any questions
at this point about the first part of
the solution
okay so how can we get rid of the random
article
so the high level idea is we are going
to replace the random article with a
carbon
combinatorial object called the sampler
which is equivalent to
a seated extractor so you won't have to
understand what an extractor is to
understand the scheme
um i mean of course it's also not that
simple like it's not just replacing the
random article
with sampler and you are done that won't
work uh we'll need some extra tools
so in this picture we have a sampler you
can think of it as a bipartite
expander graph the graph has very good
randomness like properties
each vertex on the left can be
identified by a bit string
and we'll think of the vertices on the
right as the end players
so basically every vertex on the left
selects
the uh players so the degree of the
vertex
the degree of every left vertex is
exactly d so it's a d
regular i mean for the vertices on the
left
it's the irregular
okay so here's a straw man idea
let's say the players they jointly
select
um a vertex on the left right they each
post a bit
onto the blockchain we concatenate all
their bits
it selects the left vertex and then the
left vertex
will select the size d committee
okay
so we can try to analyze the scheme
uh so in this example imagine the first
two bits are contributed by the honest
player so they're in blue and the last
four bits are red
because they're contributed by the
coilusion and
we are the proof is a combinatorial
argument
and one thing that's worth mentioning is
like earlier when we relied on the
random article in the proof
we relied on the fact that the adversary
can only make polynomially many random
article queries
but here the argument is of a different
nature it's like a
combinatorial argument it doesn't
depend on the computational bound on the
adversary
okay so here's roughly the way the
argument works i'm not going to
go into the parameter the details of the
parameter so at a very high level
suppose we fix a coalition
and
if a left vertex uh selects a bad
committee right so a bad committee is
more than 991
99.1 corrupt so if it selects a bad
committee
uh we say this left vertex is bad and we
put a cross on it
and in this bipartite graph as i said
it's called the sampler
it gives very good random sampling type
of properties
essentially no matter how you choose
your 99 coalition
the number of bad vertices on the left
is very small
okay so in fact the number of bad points
are so rare
and such that essentially
for many of these honest kind choices
and they cannot be denied
so maybe a little bit more precisely no
matter how the adversary chooses the 99
coalition the bad points on the left are
so rare
such that almost all chinese almost all
choices of honest coins
cannot be denied and here what does it
mean to be like cannot be denied
um we say that a set of honest coins
cannot be denied
if there just does not exist a coalition
choice of coins
that can lead to a bad outcome that
leads to a bad point on the left
so it doesn't matter even if the
coalition is unbounded because like
there's no effort to choose um these red
numbers for the point to be bad
okay so in this case in this sense if
the honest players just pick
random coins chances are you know no
matter how the adversarial coalition
chooses we are in good shape
okay so unfortunately this is very nice
but the parameters actually don't work
out and i'm going to explain
and i'll explain how to fix it so um
essentially we want the committee to be
poly lock science right so let's just
say log to the nine
so d is the degree of each left vertex
it's also the committee size
um sorry to jump in
just a reminder about the time if you
can maybe a few minutes
okay yeah i think i mean this is coming
to the end so
maybe i'll skip the calculation but
the point is like if we want the polylog
size committee
we we can show that like you want to
start with polylock players like roughly
speaking
lock uh cube players you cannot start
with m players because
otherwise there's just like too many
combinations the the adversary can
choose
so let me kind of skip this calculation
and so it seems like we haven't made any
progress because like
you know what we need here is to be able
to select a preliminary committee
and that's log cube size right so we're
back to the same problem
um well it turns out that it's actually
more subtle because like
in fact we are not back to the same
problem and the key idea here
is that we are going to use the
preliminary committee this log cube size
preliminary committee
to select a final committee among the
entire universe of
and players not not just among the
preliminary committee so the preliminary
preliminary committee's job is to run a
protocol like the random article
kind of protocol before but now
replacing with sampler
to select the final committee and the
final committee
is basically everyone is a candidate not
just the preliminary committee
okay and then from the final committee
we are going to run the tournament tree
protocol
to select the winner so in fact it turns
out for this
because of this key observation we only
need the preliminary committee to
satisfy a weaker property in other words
we only needed to
um like have enough honest players in
the
preliminary committee and we don't care
about
coalition honey and individual or small
coalition benefiting
itself like for this preliminary
committee we just need like some
statistical property over the population
okay so fortunately um
if we just want this weaker guarantee
there is actually a solution right we
can run
um the a single iteration of figures the
famous lightest beam protocol so i won't
go into
the lightest beam protocol but just
believe me that it works
and then once we select uh down to this
poly log size preliminary
committee that's guaranteed to be one
percent honest we can then run
this random article kind of protocol
we've seen
right to select a final committee but
now we are not going to use a random
article we are going to use the sampler
instead
okay so remember you know we are still
going to use the same tricks as before
like we are going to use
the virtual id trick and we are going to
use the honest majority npc
in the second step to defend against the
attacks we've seen
so that's kind of the whole protocol
i'll defer to the paper
for formal definition and description of
the protocol and proofs
so i'll conclude but i want to just say
a few quick words about the stronger
notion
the sequential fairness notion we
actually prove in the paper
so i've actually cheated a little so far
like the definition i told you
is not always incentive compatible um
like let's take one aspect of the
definition for example
basically the coalition cannot benefit
itself by more than epsilon
i mean the problem is like when epsilon
is not a negligible function
um there could be a bad event
that happens with small but
non-negligible probability let's say
epsilon over two probability
and if this bad event happens you always
want to deviate like let's say the bad
event is the coalition still
uh change this password if i steal your
password
i might as well crack your bitcoin
account and steal all your
bitcoins rather than following the
protocol but when we take the expected
utility
this bad event gets averaged out because
it happens with very small probability
right
so in some sense this basic notion i
talked about
doesn't rule out some protocols where
you know
with epsilon probability i might want to
deviate
like there's maybe a small probability
that event that incentivizes me
to deviate so in in our paper we have
like
a better solution concept that solves
this problem
which we call sequential fairness and
i'll defer to the paper for the
full details
and and our work is also related to some
previous work in the crypto literature
like for instance is related to rational
protocol design
like our non-sequential notion can
actually can be proven
to be equivalent to a multiple
multiplicative variant of this rational
protocol design notion
but our sequential notion is stronger
and also we observed that in some
earlier papers like fruit chain
their approximate fairness notion is
like in some sense lacking because it
doesn't have the sequential aspect
um okay so i want to conclude by saying
you know game theory needs crypto type
of work is much needed for the
decentralized blockchain space
and in this area actually interestingly
industry adoption is uh
way ahead of research and we need um
basically new scientific foundations
because a lot of the times
like even the formulation of the problem
is not clear
we need interdisciplinary work in this
area so
it's an exciting area in my opinion
thanks
thank you elaine um and also club club
um er other questions for elaine
um
so i have a question so um i mean for a
while the protocol looked
i mean as we were building it pretty
cute
and unreasonable and then it kind of
went
quickly went out of control into much
more complex
would you would you guess that there is
a i don't know
a better protocol from the book that uh
er
is simpler and maybe gives similar
guarantees and maybe is uh
maybe gets better constants or is a
friendly deployment or
what's your assessment of this problem
so for
deployment i've actually thought about
it a little bit and i think the the
random article-based protocol like some
modification of it
might be like i think it's implementable
like the question is how do you realize
the honest majority mpc
but the functionality we need here is
actually very simple i think you'll
probably only need like
verifiable secret sharing um and then
the latter part where we get
get rid of the random article i think
mostly it's like
interesting theoretically um
and i don't have great ideas how to
simplify it yet but i think it would be
very interesting to get simpler
constructions
without the random article
i mean i think conceptually it's kind of
like simple right it's like this random
article based approach and you just want
to replace the random article with the
sampler
and then but it's just not all that easy
to directly replace it with the sampler
and maybe that's where
it got a little complicated we have to
do this two-phase approach like
preliminary committee
and then final committee and then
tournament three
yeah cool thanks
er so maybe since this is running a
little bit uh
late i i would like to encourage uh
everyone if they want especially the
speakers if
they want to socialize or ask more
questions to the speakers
and there's a link i just put in chat
for um
socializing we're gonna take a one-hour
break so we're gonna sort of
resume for the two afternoon talks at
the
noon california time but it's a little
over and
so yeah thanks again for both speakers
the link is the same as the one sent in
the email or it's a different one
yeah it's the same the workshop yeah
sounds good yeah all right see you later